[MUSIC PLAYING]
>> What I really think we need to do is make
FGM much more explicit.
The data, the porosity of the data is shocking.
There is a lot that's out there.
But how can we ascertain the global scale
of this issue if we don't
actually know what we're dealing with ?
The 3 million figure we're all quoting is
in Africa alone.
It doesn't tackle Indonesia, Yemen, UAE.
It doesn't tackle Europe, where we know 500,000
women are living with
FGM.
So we don't understand the scale.
We don't understand what needs to be done
on a country-by-country basis
to tackle the problem.
A solution in Indonesia is completely different
to what we need in
Cameroon, in Sierra Leone, as in Senegal.
We need to be very, very cognizant of what
is the global action plan?
Without that, we can't cost a solution.
If this is a matter of resources, then great.
Let's just get on and fundraise.
But until we are much more aware about the
global scale of this problem
and what needs to be done about it, we can't
reach that target of 2015.
I think very kind offer from an NGO already
working in this field ---
thank you, I'll be in touch -- but equally,
all the NGOs working in
this area, please get FGM on your agenda.
Do something more about it.
And I've run out of steam.
Go to my my website.
There are five easy things that you can do.
They may seem little things.
But lastly, do what you can.
This is going out to the YouTube community.
They'll be people watching all over the world.
I chose to enter a competition on Davos; you
may want to find out what
is happening in your local community.
You may wish to fundraise.
You may wish to push your government on various
things or your MP.
Know what your action is; what your agency
is.
And please just do something.
It's international FGM day, sorry.
International anti-FGM day on the sixth of
February.
That's a week from today.
Contact a journalist.
Talk about FGM. Thank you.
>>Don't feel you have to contact this journalist
in particular.
I'm already on board.
Ann?
>> Well, certainly I would agree with all
that's been said.
But I think it's -- first of all, so important
to recognize that this
is first and foremost a violation of the rights
of the girl child.
Think about the fact that most of the people,
the children who are
subjected to this are between about the ages
of 4 and maybe 12.
I mean, this is a human being that really
doesn't have the right to say
no.
It's imposed on her.
The second thing I would say is that everyone
should look at those
organizations that are working in this arena.
It isn't a popular cause.
These organizations can't generate lots of
resources for their work.
And so support those organizations that are
truly making a difference
in this area.
>> Um, let me just also say finally that,
you know, this is indeed just
part of a broader puzzle.
And that quite aside from the simple moral
issue, it's imminently
practical issue we're not going to make progress
against global
poverty, against insecurity unless girls are
brought into the picture
brought into the formal economy, educated,
and so on.
This is one facet of that larger picture.
And then we really hope that you whether you're
here, right here, or
watching on YouTube, you will get engaged.
And I think Julia really deserves our thanks
and appreciation for
bringing this issue to Davos and to YouTube
to the Davos debate.
And please join me in thanking her and all
of the panelists here today.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]